[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité a déjà eu deux vies sa vie
d'athlète de très haut niveau et une vie
disons plus politique plus médiatique en
fait il est le visage des jo de paris
2024 ça fait pas mal d'années maintenant
qu'il met toute son énergie dans ce
projet parce que président du comité
d'organisation des jeux ce n'est pas une
petite affaire les enjeux économiques
sociaux et même sociétaux sont
absolument gigantesque interdit de se
louper les jo d'été à paris c'est arrivé
deux fois dans l'histoire les derniers
c'était il ya un siècle vous l'avez
compris la pression sur les épaules de
notre invité est énorme mais pourquoi
pourquoi s'est-il lancé dans une
aventure si périlleuse avait-il besoin
de retrouver l'adrénaline des finales
olympiques de canoë et bien on va lui
poser toutes ces questions bienvenue
dans un monde un regard bienvenue tony
estanguet merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans ce dom tournon du sénat
pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes-vous lancé
là dedans c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser
la question vous aviez vraiment besoin
de retrouver une autre forme
d'adrénaline oui bonjour d'abord écouter
c'est vrai qu'à la fin de ma carrière
sportive je me suis demandé ce que
j'allais devenir comme beaucoup de
sportifs de haut niveau après avoir
passé vingt ans à me spécialiser dans un
sport j'avais besoin d'un défi et c'est
vrai que le sport a changé ma vie j'ai
aussi cette conviction que le sport
pourrait apporter encore davantage à la
société française et qu'il fallait un
grand projet dont quand on m'a proposé
de faire partie de cette équipe qui
allait se lancer dans ce défi de faire
gagner la france pour accueillir les
jeux en 2024 j'avais envie effectivement
de ce nouveau défi york je parlais
d'enjeux colossaux est ce qui vous
arrive d'avoir peur et pour le dire même
plus franchement vous avez la trouille
oui bien évidemment je pense que c'est
effectivement un projet complexe et le
plus grand projet que la france n'ait
jamais organisé on va accueillir le
monde de 106 pays 15 un peu moins de 15
millions de billons de billets seront en
vente à la cca colossal quinze mille
athlètes ont participé à ces joueuses et
les peurs ou pas oui moi j'ai peur de
tout ça parce que les enjeux sont
importants et donc il faut être au
rendez vous la france ne peut pas se
rater entre guillemets on est un grand
pays des attentes sont très grandes mais
quand je me déplace un peu partout sur
la planète ayant se disent whaou les
jeux à paris en france ça fait rêver
c'est plus difficile parfois que la
pression du sport de très haut niveau
c'est très différent tous les cas moi
j'ai appris à me spécialiser à maîtriser
chacun des paramètres de ma performance
le petit détail qui fait la différence
tout était sous contrôle mais quand même
je ré emploi je réutilise ce que j'ai
appris dans ma carrière d'athlète c'est
à dire la capacité à s'adapter en
permanence quand vous êtes sportif de
haut niveau surtout dans mon sport le
canoë-kayak j'étais dans un milieu assez
aléatoire avec des vagues qui bougeait
qui changeait tous les jours donc je
devais quand même m'adapter à un
environnement a cédé
aujourd'hui ça m'aide à faire face un
peu à ce stress de passe de savoir
toujours comment on va organiser des
jeux comment est ce qu'on va trouver des
solutions quand de nouvelles difficultés
arrivent parce qu'il ya des retards dans
les travaux parce que si parce que ça il
peut y avoir des aléas bon quelque part
on a des solutions dans ce pays pour
organiser des jeux exceptionnels sauf
que votre sport est plutôt individuelle
là c'est j'imagine une aventure très
collective est ce que c'est mieux c'est
moins bien à l'époque vous pouviez
compter que sur vous là vous pouvez
compter sur d'autres et c'est ça qui m'a
plu ce nom ce nouveau défi justement à
la fin de ma carrière j'ai envie de
tourner la page de ma carrière sportive
pour justement retrouver de l'adrénaline
mais dans un projet très collectif et
c'est ce que je trouve magique
aujourd'hui d'être capable de réussir à
fédérer le mouvement sportif toutes ces
fédérations qui sont au coeur du
dispositif avec les athlètes en première
ligne mais aussi les acteurs économiques
qui vont financer ces jeux 97 % du
budget du comité d'organisation est
financé par les entreprises et puis les
acteurs publics qui ont un rôle très
important à jouer aussi pour nous
accompagner vers la réussite et donc ça
nécessite de coordonner voilà des
centaines d'entités qui doivent
contribuer à la réussite et et donner le
meilleur visage quelque part de la
france ces jeux ils seront réussies si
quoi pour vous s'il ya une émulation
collective si ça crée des emplois c'est
au nombre de médailles que pour vous à
quelles conditions ces jeux vous
considérez que ces jeux sont réussis
pour moi ces jeux ils doivent être
encore une fois le reflet du meilleur de
la france et donc nous nous jetons les
voeux réussi à condition d'être
spectaculaire parce que les jeux c'est
des émotions et quelque part organiser
des compétitions
au pied de la tour eiffel dans les
jardins du château de versailles au
grand palais aux invalides c'est quelque
part mais les le meilleur de notre
patrimoine avec les émotions des
sportifs mais c'est aussi des jeux plus
exemplaire parce que les jeux
aujourd'hui doivent quelque part se
connecter aux défis de notre société et
donc c'est réduire de moitié les
émissions carbone par exemple en
utilisant 95% des infrastructures qui
sont déjà existantes c'est des jeux plus
paritaires et donc on va multiplier ses
engagements aussi pour que on démontre
que c'est possible organiser les jeux
différemment par rapport à tout ce qui
s'est fait et cfm un antidote à la
morosité ambiante oui je crois que c'est
on en a besoin je crois qu'on a besoin
de se raccrocher à un horizon positif en
sortie de crise sanitaire je crois
encore une fois que le sport peut être
un horizon très positif il démontre que
ils continuent à être les meilleures
audiences ces temps forts où les gens se
retrouvent partage des émotions vont
dans la rue pour partager une grande
victoire mais c'est aussi au quotidien
un vecteur de bien-être toutes les
études scientifiques démontrent que pour
vivre longtemps et en bonne santé il
faut pratiquer de manière régulière le
sport les jeux se sont aussi souvent
disons le des polémiques des polémiques
sur des infrastructures vieillissantes
qui finalement sont abandonnées après
les jeux comment vous appréhendez tout
ça justement on a on a revu complètement
le modèle on s'est dit on va on va
vraiment essayer de penser des jeux
différents un nouveau modèle
d'organisation
95% de l'infrastructure existante parce
qu'on a vu dans le passé que les
dépassements budgétaires venait sur les
infrastructures toujours donc quelque
part en réduisant
complètement on va construire dix fois
moins d'équipements par rapport aux
dernières éditions même par rapport à
l'ombre donc quelque part voilà on
réduit les risques de dépassement
budgétaire et ensuite c'est mettre nos
moyens justement sur comment est ce
qu'on apporte des solutions pour
développer la place du sport dans la
société ce programme de 30 minutes de
sport à l'école primaire par exemple
aujourd'hui l'organisation mondiale de
la santé dit que 80% de nos adolescents
ne font pas suffisamment de sport en
france on est classé 117e pays sur 140
en matière de sédentarité donc on a un
vrai défi collectif a relevé et quelque
part les jeux qui sont le plus grand
événement sportif de la planète doit
être aussi en moyen de de développer la
place du sport du sport loisir c'est une
compétition un peu suranné qu'elle a
fait son temps qu'elle est un peu
dépassée vous n'êtes pas d'accord et
cela non moi je suis pas d'accord avec
ça alors après je suis pas complètement
objectif parce que j'ai fait les jeux
j'ai vu ce que ça a apporté dans un pays
je sais aussi au delà des émotions bien
aujourd'hui si moi je suis épanouie si
du moins je suis en bonne santé c'est
parce que j'ai pratiqué le sport je
continue à pratiquer le sport est
quelque part si moi j'ai commencé le
sport quand j'étais tout gamin c'est
parce que des champions m'ont fait m'ont
fait rêver et donc il faut garder ces
événements sportifs de très haut niveau
qui sont des moments où on idéalise où
on faire il faut faire rêver la jeunesse
il faut leur donner envie de de
pratiquer des sports on a aujourd'hui
cette chance d'avoir 180 mille clubs
partout dans ce pays en france avec
plein de disciplines différentes il ya
forcément un sport pour vous quel que
soit votre goût quel que soit votre âge
aller dans un club et vous verrez que
pour votre santé vous serez bien mais
vous allez aussi vous faire plaisir vous
allez rencontrer du monde et c'est
aujourd'hui un vecteur d'inclusion il
échoit le sport qui braquent aussi qui
fâchent breakdance par exemple ouais
c'est alors c'est vrai que quand on veut
organiser cet événement d'une manière
différente
de temps en temps ça fâche un peu on
sait qu'il ya toujours une résistance au
changement une résistance il ya un
conservatisme mais si on veut organiser
les jeux de la france le meilleur de la
france à travers par et 2024 il faut
aussi faire des choix du breakdance
parce qu'il ya une polémique a
effectivement autour de ceux de votre
choix oui d'inscrire le breakdance en
compétition au détriment d'autres
disciplines comme le caractère part
exactement il y avait 19 sport qui ont
candidaté on pouvait en retenir quatre
ans sport additionnel on a privilégié la
complémentarité parce que la magie des
jeux c'est cette diversité des sports
pour la pendant deux semaines de
compétition on en prend plein les yeux
collectif un choc vous assumez oui c'est
un choix qu'on assume parce que
justement on a voulu aller
agrémenté compléter justement cette
diversité sportive est aujourd'hui le
breakdance que vous citez c'est un sport
de rue qui nécessite pas de moyens et
qui a le vent en poupe aussi donc
c'était important aussi de leur donner
leur chance de démontrer cet univers
artistique et sportif je le disais en
introduction votre tâche est devenu très
politique finalement votre exercice
quotidien c'est aussi disons le rhin
d'aller serrer des mains de sourire de
convaincre de plaire j'imagine que c'est
pas simple tous les jours ça a été
compliqué s'adapter à st oui forcément
ça a été compliqué c'est pas mon univers
et c'est pas forcément mon moteur
aujourd'hui mais c'est mon rôle
effectivement en tant que président de
paris 2004 c'est de fédérer d'embarquer
un peu tout le monde pour l'instant
jusqu'ici jamais de déception jamais de
coups bas j'aime et de trahison quelque
chose que vous pourriez dévoiler ici par
exemple non des difficultés forcément au
quotidien parce que encore une fois
quand on doit aligner tout le monde bah
c'est pas toujours facile tout le monde
n'est pas forcément tout le temps
d'accord mais globalement il ya quand
même un super compromis même au niveau
politique je vois bien où vous voulez
m'emmener je travaille aujourd'hui
régulièrement avec des acteurs voilà qui
sont dans le combat politique aussi de
temps en temps mais qui sur l'intérêt
politique exactement mais sur la cause
des jeux se retrouvent et aujourd'hui
plusieurs d'entre eux sont candidats à
une élection ça ne les empêche pas de
venir participer aux réunions de
pareilles 1024 et quelque part de
contribuer au meilleur de ce projet par
les dan hidalgo la part d'anne hidalgo
du président de la république de valérie
pécresse qui sont tous embarqués en
première ligne sur par et 2024 et qui
mettent de côté leur rivalité politique
pour faire en sorte que ce projet
réussisse et aujourd'hui on est dans les
temps on est toujours dans le budget il
ya aucun dépassement budgétaire et on a
un projet d'exception de la magie des
jeux c'est les réunit elle est
rassemblée autour d'une même si c'est ça
et surtout de le réunir eux mais aussi
les athlètes et aussi les entreprises
qui financent les jeux et donc cesser
cette ce défi là qui nous animent au
quotidien c'est pour ça que c'est
intense
importe il justement les jo alors vous
l'avez dit c'est d'abord en tant
qu'athlète que vous les avez connu votre
première vie c'était le sport de très
haut niveau je vais quand même c'était
votre palmarès les médailles olympiques
vous les collectionner vous êtes le seul
français à avoir gagné trois médailles
d'or lors des jeux olympiques différents
lors à sydney en 2000 lors à athènes en
2004 petit accident à pékin on va y
revenir en deux 8 et demi finaliste mais
vous revenez sans médaille et l'or à
londres en 2012 est ce que c'est parce
que vous perdez à pékin que vous gagnez
à londres c'est bien possible en tous
les cas je peux vous dire que cette
défaite à pékin elle a été très riche
d'enseignements pour moi ça a été une
énorme claque parce que clairement
j'allais à pékin pour essayer de gagner
et d'enchaîner ces trois 3 victoires
voilà une petite touche à la porte 3 en
demi finale effectivement me sort de la
finale donc ça a été dur parce que ça a
été une grosse remise en question la
question aussi j'avais 30 ans à ce
moment là la question d'arrêter ma
carrière ou de continuer et je peux vous
dire que les quatre années qui ont suivi
la défaite de pékin ont été supers
riches parce que humainement il a fallu
se reconstruire il a fallu imaginer et
créer quelque part une nouvelle manière
de me préparer parce qu'on peut pas
gagner les jeux à 34 ans comme je les
avais gagné à 22 ans à signer pour mes
premiers jeux et donc c'est cette
adaptation qui a été vraiment nécessaire
pour moi pendant ces quatre dernières
années de ma carrière est très riche mon
frère était avec votre frère c'est ce
que ça devient une aventure familiale ce
moment là ce que j'ai été adversaires
avec mon frère pendant longtemps sur mes
premières olympiades et puis quand il a
arrêté sa carrière puisque c'est mon
aîné je lui propose effectivement de
devenir mon entraîneur et on a partagé
cette dernière olympiade ensemble et on
est allé chercher l'or à londres en 2012
c'est l'échec du cookie
vous fait remporté donc cette médaille
et qui du coup créer une ambition encore
plus forte qui vous qui vous donne
encore plus faim
bonjour le thouars en tous les cas je
trouve que c'était intéressant pour moi
d'être capable de gérer un échec de la
de l'assumer de l'accepter de l'analyser
parce qu'il n'ya pas toujours tout à
jeter dans un échec il ya souvent aussi
et ça s'est joué à pas grand chose et
quelque part c'est cette qualité là
aussi qui m'a qui m'a permis d'aller
chercher leur à londres et aujourd'hui
quand encore une fois on a des voix qui
se ferment parce qu'elles sont
impossibles on essaie de les contourner
on s'est trouvé d'autres solutions
d'être créatif et de d'imaginer un
nouveau modèle d'organisation des jeux
comme à l'époque j'ai imaginé une
nouvelle manière de gagner les jeux le
31 juillet 2012 donc lorsque vous
remporté sept médailles historiques
cette médaille d'or historique à londres
vous dites que vous avez été en phase
avec les éléments c'est la fois
magnifique et terrifiant ce que ça veut
dire que ça tient à rien une victoire ça
tient à rien franchement ça tient à rien
même si je peux vous dire que chaque
dixième de seconde de cette manche je
lui ai encore gravé en moi se souvient
de chaque appui chaque coup de pagaie
chaque gîte dans chaque vague mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux trois fois dans la
dans la manche où je prends des risques
ça passe mais je sais aussi que ça
pourrait ne pas passer parce qu'il ya
deux trois fois où je passe à moins de 2
cm d'une touche et c'est ça qui est
assez magique parce que ça dure que 90
secondes ces quatre ans de travail
quotidien qui sont jugés sur 90 secondes
d'effort donc c'est une vraie prise de
risque fait très ce que les jets cela
je me souviens exactement de toutes mes
trajectoires ces voix là c'est grave et
non encore une fois dans mon adn
aujourd'hui et c'était ma première vie
c'était très intense mais c'est vrai que
dans quand on est sportif de haut niveau
on pousse vraiment les limites de son
corps de son stress pour pour aller
chercher un peu exceptionnelle et c'est
vrai que cette fois là pour peut-être la
première fois de toute ma carrière
sportive j'ai senti que j'étais en phase
avec les éléments que je comprenais ce
qui se passait je sentais que la vague
était en train de se former et donc
j'avais toujours un petit temps d'avant
ce parce que j'avais la vision j'avais
déjà fait ce qu'il fallait à ce moment
là j'étais un peu dans un état sûr
naturel qu'on a du mal à expliquer mais
des années d'efforts de sacrifices qui
se joue en quelques secondes ouais c'est
ça qui est magique aussi et d'accepter
de prendre des risques on maîtrise pas
tous les paramètres
c'est un sport assez aléatoire mais
cruel aussi mais c'est des fois c'est
cruel en 2008 ça a été un peu cruel pour
moi et c'était dur mais c'était
intéressant aussi de le vivre parce que
c'est une bonne dose d'humilité et on en
a besoin dans la vie aussi de temps en
temps de prendre des petits coups
d'humidité et ça remet les idées en
place et puis ensuite on repart au
combat le message d'humilité vous le
portez auprès des politiques que vous
fréquentez pas réglo le monde
particulièrement j'ai un document pour
vous alors je vais vous le donner aux
mains propres et puis je vais le décrire
pour les gens qui nous écoutent c'est un
document transmis par les archives
nationales qui sont nos partenaires sur
cette émission et je vous le dis parce
que c'est écrit tout petit c'est un
rapport d'activité de la fédération
française de canoë qui date de 1946 je
vous lis ce qui est écrit en 46 le canoë
n'est pas un sport spectaculaire et les
recettes qui sont faites à l'occasion de
matches ou rencontres sont pratiquement
insignifiante nous avons donc l'honneur
pour ces deux organisations de
solliciter l'obtention d'une subvention
spéciale ça vous inspire quoi ça vous
rappelle des choses ça vous peut-être ça
nous dit que le canoë a quand même
souvent dans l'histoire était un sport
malmené ouais je pense que c'est ça fait
partie de ces sports un peu
méconnu entre guillemets et qui vit
effectivement grâce au soutien d'acteurs
publics mais c'est aussi le modèle
français quelque part du sport en
général on a cette chance entre
guillemets d'avoir des acteurs publics
les communes au premier chef qui partout
dans le territoire accompagne avec des
subventions des petits clubs entre
guillemets de sport mais qui permettent
à des millions de français de faire du
sport des millions de rencontre tous les
week-ends dans toutes les villes il ya
des petits matches de football le sport
collectif de sport individuel et ça crée
du lien c'est le cas dans tous les pays
non c'est pas de quand tu payes est et
ses quelques pays elle avoue c'est très
privée où il ya moins d'accompagnement
public et je pense qu'on doit être fier
de ce modèle là parce que c'est grâce à
ce modèle que des sports comme le mien
que des sports dits mineurs entre guinée
c'est spectaculaire comme c'est
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui si on faisait
la même étude d'un certain dirais que ce
transport qui est plus spectaculaire que
d'autres mais voilà en tous les cas ça
permet de garder cette richesse sportive
et moi personnellement j'ai grandi dans
un univers sportif où je me suis essayée
à des sports très différent des sports
collectifs des sports d'intérieur des
sports d'extérieur et je trouve ça assez
magique dans notre pays encore une fois
de pouvoir aller en montagne de pouvoir
aller sur le littoral de pouvoir aller
dans des sports d'intérieur et quelque
part de prendre du plaisir et c'est
cette diversité sportif qu'il faut
absolument conserver et entre guillemets
préservé mais vous regrettez que parfois
on dise un sport n'est pas assez
spectaculaire et qu'on en change les
règles pour qu'ils soient plus
spectaculaires justement moi je n'ont
pas forcément je pense que le monde du
sport doit aussi se remettre en question
et de temps en temps il faut faire
évoluer
l'offre sportive parce que quelque part
on doit répondre à une attente des
consommateurs et des français qui ont
envie un plaisir plus rapide d'apprendre
en apprentissage plus facile parce que
des fois c'est dur moi je me suis dans
mon enseignement du canoë kayak
dans les eaux du gave des pyrénées il
faisait froid l'eau était froide c'était
dur on n'avait pas du super matériel
aujourd'hui bon bain les jeunes ils ont
du matériel qui sont qu'une meilleure
qualité on a moins froid on a des
bateaux qui sont plus faciles à manier
et tant mieux quelque part qu'on soit
capable de faire évoluer ces sports là
mais vous dites parfois qu'il y en a
quand même un peu que pour le foot est
un peu pour le rugby en france on est
lui toujours en scène ya toujours sept 7
petites jalousies effectivement mais oui
et c'est déjà louzy des autres athlètes
des autres sportifs puis la frustration
parce que c'est vrai que nous quand on
vient dans ce sport on trouve que c'est
le plus beau sport parce qu'on y prend
du plaisir au quotidien
mais quand même globalement je trouve
qu'on a beaucoup de chance encore une
fois en france d'avoir ce modèle qui
garantit à une centaine il ya 107
fédérations sportives dans notre pays
contrairement à d'autres pays qui ont
fait des choix de vouloir entre
guillemets ne choisir que des sports qui
offre des médailles par exemple moi je
suis pas forcément à ça parce que le
sport c'est d'abord du sport loisir
c'est d'abord du plaisir ensuite on peut
faire du haut niveau pour certains si on
peut être que parfois les millions qui
sont sur la table viennent dénaturer le
sport si vous vous dites ça notamment
évidemment je pense moi alors moi je
suis contre ce ce débat de vouloir
opposer le sport pro le sport loisir je
pense que le sport loisir vie grâce au
sport professionnel l'argent récolté
générés par le football quelque part il
bénéficie aussi à tout l'écosystème
sportif au sens large et donc voilà je
pense qu'il faut garder des grands
matches professionnels des grands
moments de sport professionnel parce que
quelque part ça fait le lien avec le
sport loisir et on est tous aussi
content de voir une équipe de france qui
gagne la coupe du monde ça donne envie à
beaucoup de gens de faire du sport et le
sport à l'école vous le trouver
suffisamment valorisée
le ps appelle son physique et sport pour
moi il ya une marge de progression
clairement j'ai envie qu'on valorise
davantage je sais que les professeurs
d'éducation physique et sportive de ps
ils font du bon boulot moi j'ai deux
frères qu'ils le sont et il manque
souvent de moyens douala
rien c'est pas toujours très bien
valorisé c'est pas une matière qui est
très bien valorisé à les conseils de
classe quand on a 5 ans sport en général
cela pose pas très grave c'est dommage
parce qu'on voit aussi malheureusement
que le niveau sportif des élèves
aujourd'hui il réduit ils chutent les
élèves d'aujourd'hui sont en moins bonne
santé en moins bon niveau sportif qui a
40 ans et ça c'est un peu alertant parce
que normalement ça ne devrait pas être
le cas aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans
une une société qui est plus moderne qui
a un meilleur accès à la pratique du
sport et malheureusement on voit que les
jeunes sont de plus en plus sédentaires
ils passent de plus en plus de temps
devant leur écran encore une fois 80 %
des adolescents ne font pas 30 minutes
de sport par jour mais j'imagine que le
colis des dû faire beaucoup de mal aux
6es du sédentarisés encore davantage ses
gestes aggraver la situation observée
soit aggravé la situation
malheureusement il y avait déjà une
tendance à la sédentarité mais le coc
vide est passé par dessus et aujourd'hui
malheureusement il ya encore moins de
jeunes actifs et donc là on a un vrai
défi collectif en sortie de crise
d'accompagner justement parce que encore
une fois le meilleur moyen de ne pas
tomber malade c'est d'être en bonne
santé et pour être en bonne santé c'est
non négociable
il faut pratiquer au moins 30 minutes
d'activités sportives par jour il s'agit
de marcher de faire du vélo de monter
les escaliers on vous demande pas d'être
en sportif assidu très avec beaucoup
d'intensité mais a minima d'organiser
votre journée pour aller à un
rendez-vous à pied pour descendre d'une
station de métro un peu plus tôt pour
retrouver une volonté entre guillemets
de bouger un petit peu plus parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on va réussir à ce que
la population française soit en
meilleure santé et dans le sport de haut
niveau vous craignez même un problème du
vivier est ce que vous craignez un
moment donné on n'est pas assez
d'athlètes de haut niveau dans certains
sports c'est proportionnel - en a deux
c'est une pyramide en fait le sport de
haut niveau donc moins on a deux mondes
à la base de la pyramide qui pratiquent
le sport et moins on a de chance d'avoir
du nombre entre guillemets en haut de la
pyramide donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un
défi pour alimenter effectivement la
filière du sport de haut niveau aussi
d'avoir plus de pratique en loisirs mais
encore une fois pour moi le vrai défi
c'est d'abord que ces jeunes aient envie
de s'éclater envie de de faire du sport
de s'accrocher parce que c'est vrai que
les premières séances de sport c'est
toujours un peu difficile on n'est pas
très à l'aise mais dès qu'on franchit ce
cap là on prend du plaisir et là on vit
des choses assez assez unique mais vous
devez en parler cela de cela quand vous
allez dans les couloirs des deux soit de
l'elysée soit du ministère des sport
j'imagine que vous portez ce message qu
est ce qu on vous répond vous dis oui on
sai on y va on va mettre l'argent qu'il
faut maintenant c'est compliqué il ya
plein d'arbitrage on doit mettre de
l'argent partout non non j'ai chauveau
redmen il ya une écoute franchement il
ya quand même une écoute depuis deux ans
je trouve que les choses sont en train
de d'évoluer positivement le ministère
éducation nationale a décidé de mettre
ses trente minutes de sport par jour
dans les écoles primaires on a fait une
expérimentation avec paris 1024 ya deux
ans dans une centaine d'écoles là on a
dépassé le millier d'écoles maintenant
qu'ils mettent en place tous les jours
dans les écoles primaires c'est trente
minutes de sport par jour parce que les
études démontrent que un élève qui bouge
un petit peu plus quand il revient en
classe il est plus concentré il mange
bio à la cantine il dort mieux le soir
et donc quelque part il est plus
épanouie ces cercles vertueux mais ça
c'est important pour moore d'enclencher
une nouvelle dynamique pour donner envie
aux jeunes de faire du sport alors c'est
pas le ministre de l'éducation nationale
que je vais vous montrer c'est une autre
ministre c'est roxana maracineanu elle
même ancien sportif de haut niveau est
évidemment devenu ministre des sports
championne du monde de natation en 81 18
médailles d'argent aux jo de sydney et
vous après les jeux ministre des sports
ah non je sais pas du tout là je peux
vous dire que je sais je sais pas où ces
noms c'est un non ferme c'est un jeu
c'est pas alors aujourd'hui je mets
toute mon énergie sur les 1024 je n'ai
aucune idée je pense que je vais prendre
un peu de vacances après 2000 24 mai
sérieusement est-ce que c'est le type de
défi qui pourrait
vous aimez les défis jamais vous avez
une vision de l'avenir pour le sport
intense ça fait partie des qualités
qu'on demande à un ministre des sports
ouais mais je sais aussi que pour
réussir moi j'ai besoin de mettre toute
mon énergie dans mon projet quand
j'étais sportif de haut niveau j'avais
du mal à me dire qu'est ce que je vais
faire après je savais pas trop là je
suis dans paris 2024 et je sais que
quelque part mon avenir professionnel
après par emile 1 4 il dépend de la
réussite de ce projet si ça réussit
j'aurai des opportunités 6 ainsi pas ça
sera plus difficile donc voilà je suis à
fond là dedans j'ai aucune idée de ce
que je ferai à préparer 2024 et j'ai pas
d'objectif aujourd'hui la peur du vide
ou pas vous avez un peu peuple de
vertige du vide puisque vous avez
enchaîné entre athlètes de haut niveau
puis cette aventure des jo après il y en
aura forcément d'autres évidemment qui
vous seront proposés mais ce que parfois
ça donne le vertige désert qu'est ce que
je vais faire après qu'est-ce qui va
être à 7 à ce niveau-là d'adrénaline et
de challenge oui forcément j'ai peur du
vide j'ai peur de quelque part de de
régresser j'ai toujours été mobilisés
par cette envie de progresser d'avancer
de me fixer des objectifs plus haut là
c'est vrai que pour un premier projet
professionnel après ma carrière sportive
n'est pas régresser voilà ça va être
très difficile donc il va falloir
changer de logiciel aussi je pense pour
moi et accepter de faire des choses très
différentes probablement parce que
j'arriverai pas retrouvé dans le monde
du sport un projet avec autant de défis
entre guillemets ministre si on verra on
verra à ce moment-là mais pour l'instant
vraiment je veux réussir ces jeux on
poursuit cette séquence photo qui est un
rituel dans notre émission cette fois je
vous montre le jamais je la jamaïque un
parent dont usain bolt à pékin en 2008
lorsqu'il bat le record du monde du 100
m alors j'ai choisi cette photo parce
que vous m'avez dit un jour en interview
il c'est en voyant usain bolt s'amuser
dans l'effort que j'ai décidé de
m'amuser de me détendre pendant mes
épreuves est ce que parfois c'est un peu
trop sérieux le prends le sport oui
chemin en tous les cas ça a été vraiment
un des moments très forts de ma carrière
sportive je trouve que usain bolt a
apporté une vraie enfin quelque chose de
très fort dans le monde du sport de haut
niveau de la légèreté de la légèreté du
plaisir de spectacles de l' envie de
partager en fait et le sport c'est ça
c'est du partage avec avec des fans avec
des supporters même avec ses adversaires
il avait cette capacité dans un sport
qui est quand même très difficile très
exigeants ça se joue là vraiment sur des
dixièmes ou des centièmes de seconde
d'être capable d'être très ouvert très
alerte très à l'aise et - c'est vrai que
à pékin j'étais arrivé avec un modèle de
performance où chaque chose était
maîtrisée contrôle et je ne voulais pas
du tout sortir de ma bulle j'avais créé
une bulle complètement hermétique en ce
moment les bulles ça nous parle mais à
l'époque c'était complètement déconnecté
et du coup je me suis dit mais mais je
rêverais d'être capable de travailler ça
et de gagner en étant beaucoup plus
ouvert et donc c'est ce que j'ai essayé
de travailler dans les quatre années qui
ont suivi pékin pour aller chercher un
nouveau modèle de performance à l'ombre
en étant beaucoup plus capable quelque
part d'être dans l'adaptation est dans
l'instant une troisième photo tony
estanguet je le dis pour les gens qui
vous regardent et m'écoutent
il s'agit de michel martikan champion de
canoë slovaque votre meilleur ennemi
j'ai envie de dire on dit que vous avez
formé tous les deux l'un des plus beaux
duels du sport moderne un adversaire
pour lequel j'imagine que vous avez du
respect et justement est-ce que c'est
aussi ma question est ce que c'est un
message que vous avez envie de diffuser
auprès des jeunes c'est à dire que
l'adversaire en sport on le respecte on
insulte pas nui en voit rien à la figure
est ce que ça fait aussi partie des
choses que vous voulez diffusée oui bien
sûr c'est à dire que grâce à martigues
en quelque part j'ai vécu ma carrière
sportive il y aurait pas eu marty quand
je pense que je n'aurais pas gagné tous
ces titres là il m'a imposé entre
guillemets le fait d'être le meilleur
possible au quotidien tous les jours
c'était une vraie référence et c'est
vrai qu'il y avait ce respect mutuel je
peux vous dire qu'on se faisait pas de
cadeau et ça a été un duel acharné
pendant vingt ans où chaque année sur
les championnats du monde on se battait
et puis il a gagné les jeux d'atlanta
j'ai gagné ce de signer j'ai gagné ceux
d'athènes il a gagné ceux de pékin et
puis de nouveau moi j'ai gagné à l'ombre
donc ça a été un mano à mano pendant
vingt ans c'était incroyable mais
quelque part on peut pas réussir seuls
et de temps en temps il nous faut des
adversaires et donc il faut le respecter
parce que grâce à des bons adversaires
on est obligé de se surpasser on est
obligé d'apprendre et ce respect il est
fondamental entre guillemets ce sont les
valeurs du sport et voilà et même si on
parlait pas la même langue au début je
peux vous dire que ce n'est pas facile
de communiquer on a appris à se
connaître et depuis l'âge de 15 ans
jusqu'à 35 ans on a vécu voilà une
vingtaine d'années absolument incroyable
j'ai une dernière question tony
estanguet qui est en lien avec le lieu
dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues qui
représente si vous regardez bien chacune
une vertu vous avez derrière vous la
sagesse nous avons ici la prudence mais
justice et l'éloquence alors vous avez
deviné un peu ma question à laquelle de
ces vertus vous identifier le plus
laquelle vous ressemble le plus le lol
alors je pense que non la sagesse je
pense que si je disais ça je pense que
ma mère appellerait tous je vais pas
dire la prudence je pense que être non
sens on est sportif besoin de m'engager
j'ai besoin de l'adac d'action
l'éloquence non plus je pense que je
suis con comme l'ours des pyrénées que
c'est pas trop mon truc en temps il en
faut des locaux
donc voilà il reste que la justice alors
la justice
quelque part c'est aussi une exigence
c'est un cadre qui permet de vivre et
moi je me retrouve bien là dedans toute
ma vie j'ai essayé de
rentrer dans un cadre mais par contre de
trouver mais mon chemin d'un vanter
d'avoir de l'audace aussi pour sortir un
peu des sentiers battus mais quand même
avec une exigence et une rigueur du
quotidien parce que sinon on peut pas
réussir et peut-être que la justice s'en
incarne un petit peu ça met un peu par
défaut alors voilà peu par défaut quand
il aurait fallu qu'il ait l'audace à la
voile à l'audace c'est vrai que ça me
botte averti merci infiniment tony soir
était notre invité dans un monde un
regard on se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat merci
[Musique]